مساء الخير الدلالات الثقافيه والدينيه
زياره البابا فرنسيس للامارات معروفه
للجميع والناس كلهم تكلموا عنها باعتبارها
انها زياره بتساعد على التقارب بين
الاديان
والتسامح ونبذ العنف كل ما تكلمت في ال
قصدي لكن الدلاله السياسيه للزياره محتاجه
منا وقفه
الحقيقه ان دعوه الامارات لبابا الكاثوليك
وزيارته لل منطقه الجزيره العربيه يعني
لاول مره منذ ظهور الاسلام
مؤشر مهم جدا على رغبه الامارات وحليفه
يعني الحرفين السعوديه ومصر والدول الاخرى
على الانفتاح على دول العالم وعلى
الديانات الاخرى
الانفتاح على العالم وعلى الدول الاخرى
احد اهم ركائز وطبعا قبول الاخر احد اهم
ركائز العلمانيه العلمانيه في تحالف واضح
ما بين اساسا في دول اخرى لكن الاساس في
هي السعوديه ومصر والامارات التحالف قائم
على قواسم مشتركه واحده من اهم القواسم
المشتركه التي لا تذكر صراحه ولكنها واضحه
هي رغبه هذا التحالف في دعم الفكره
العلمانيه كلمه العلمانيه
تكون كلمه بتخوف الناس ان صوبها مدنيه
الدوله مدنيه الدوله لو مش واضحه نقول
باختصار المقصود بها قيام دوله الدوله
نفسها لا يكون لها دين ولكن هي بتحترم تقف
على مسافه واحده من اصحاب كل الديانات كل
واحد اذا كان مواطن او مقيم او سائح من
حقه ان يمارس عباره الله كما يشاء اولا
يمارس اساسا هو حر
امثله كثيره جدا على الدول العلمانيه انك
وليكن مثلا اي دوله غربيه قد مثلا مثال
بريطانيا في او في اي مدينه لندن مثلا
بتكلم على بريطانيا هناك يمكن ان يقيم اي
انسان على الاراضي الانجليزيه ويمارس
ديانته بحريه كامله اذا كان مسلم او مسيحي
والدوله تكفله حريه ممارسه هذه الشعائر
طالما يلتزم بالقانون هذه الفكره
العلمانيه فكره العلمانيه اللي هي ليست
لدينا علشان اه تنجح وعلشان هذا المثلث
وحلفاؤه في دول اخرى اه تنجح لازم يصطدم
بافكار حاكمه في الشارع الاسلامي والشارع
العربي
افكار الشيخ ابن تيميه
افكار محمد بن عبد الله افكار ابو الاعلى
المودودي الهندي الباكستاني لاحقا افكار
الشيخ محمد رشيد رضا و حسن البنا مؤسس
جماعه الاخوان المسلمين افكار اكبر منظر
لجماعه الاخوان المسلمين وهو سيدخل
الافكار والممارسات لكل الجماعات التي
خرجت من عباءه هؤلاء المفكرين يعني اذا
كانوا جماعات معروفه زي مثلا جماعه
الاخوان المسلمين او كل الجماعات السلفيه
المختلفه ذلك مع الطالبان مثلا في
افغانستان
او الحركات شديده البطش والتطرف زي دا
عشره نصفه وغيرهم كل دون حرموا من افكار
عباءه او من عباءه هؤلاء المفكرين اي
القاسم المشترك في هؤلاء المفكرين انه
عندهم المعامله الافكار الحاكمه الفكره
الاولى فكره ال الدوله الدينيه فكره
الدوله الدينيه هي مثلا السعوديه فكره
قيامها الاولى القائمه على التحالف ما بين
حاكم عنده قوه ودعم ونفوذ الشيخ له نفوس
كبير جدا في الشارع ال او الشيخ محمد بن
عبد الوهاب
الخلافه اللي هي او الاساس في افكار كل
الجامعات اللي انا اشرت اليها فكره تقسيم
العالم اطار ايمان ودار زي ما كان يقولوا
لا على الموجوده زي ما بيقول سيد قد
المسلمين الحقيقيين كما يراه الحق دار
الاسلام وكل الماء دولي امام متاسلمين
لانه بالاساس فكره الاستعلاء على باقي انا
فكرت اللي هي استاذيه العالم ان احنا يجب
ان نقود العالم فكره اه اه عدم قبول الاخر
النظره الدونيه للمراه كل قواسم مشتركه
لافكار هؤلاء المفكر ال الانتصار الى فكره
مدنيه الدوله او العلمانيه تصطدم وكلها كل
هذه الافكار وتضع الدول الثلاث واي دوله
اخرى في المنطقه في اه فوهه المدفع لكل
هذه الجماعات النافذه والقويه خصوصا بين
الجماعات تستمد جزء من قوتها حاجتين
بس معروف انه فيه دول
دول دول بدعمهم زي في الوقت الحالي مثلا
تركيا وفي قطر الدولي عندها مصر بيقول
احنا جماعات اسلاميه وليس الجماعات
الارهابيه الاقصى ثانيه لكن انا بتكلم على
الافكار اثنين انه في دول من خارج المنطقه
واجهزه امن و مخابرات غربيه
يدعم هذه الجماعات وتوظيفها لصالحها منذ
عشرات السنوات الامر الثالث وهو المهم انه
الافكار دى كمان صعوبه المساله مش بس
الدول اللي تدعم هذه الافكار الجماعات
وبالتالي الافكار ولا اجهزه الاستخبارات
والامن الغربيه
ولكن الافكار المتكرره في الشارع الاسلامي
في كل مكان والدول ديه نفسها الدول كلها
وبما فيها الدول الثلاثه انا ذكرت وتحديدا
السعوديه انفقت مليارات الدولارات لنشر
هذه الافكار منذ الثلاثينيات
فتره قليله جدا افكار دولته انفقت مليارات
الدولارات للترويج في اوقات سابقه
الصحف الغربيه و بعض الصحف الغربيه كانت
جزء ال اثناء زياره بابا الفاتيكان
الامارات وتقول ان السعر حصل انه الجزيره
العربيه حيث مع به الاسلام استقبلت لاول
مره منذ الف واربعمائه سنه الكاثوليك هل
ممكن يحصل من قصر المستحيل وتستقبل مكه او
المدينه
الفاتيكان او اي باب اخر بهما بيتكلموا
على باب الكاثوليك اي باب اخر
الحقيقه ان السؤال ده اللي ان يحصل التغير
الكبير جدا من جانب المملكه العربيه
السعوديه
قلب العالم الاسلامي يعني كما يرى وانه
وبالتالي يكون معناها انفصال الكامل او
الطلق كامل عن مواضيع في ربط للديانات
الاخرى السؤال بطريقه اخرى بيطرح اشكاليه
هل يقدر الامير محمد
وحرفيه كان في مصر او في الامارات او في
دول اخرى انهم ينجحوا في الترويج لافكار
التسامح ونبذ العنف ومحاصره الافكار ال
شارده التطرف بحيث انه
السعوديه كدوله مدنيه عاديه قادره على
استقبال ال البابا فرنسيس او غيره سواء في
مكه او في مكه السؤال ده الاجابه عنه
تتوقف على عوامل كثيره النجاح مواجهه
الافكار المتطرفه
ولو ان المساله التطرف مسا له سميه على
الاقل من يحمل السلاح ويقبل المجتمعات او
يحاول انتظار الاخرين
الافكار مش ممكن يتم بالامس لان الافكار
يمكن محاصرتها بالسلاح لكن يمكن محاصرتها
الحوار والجدل وافكار تناطح افكار يعني
يكون في حيويه في المجتمع مفكرين يردوا
علي مفكرين في حاجه ثانيه اهم فتره نجاح
النموذج اللي بيدو اقليه تحالف ان يكون في
عمليه التنميه التنميه معناه تخلق فرص
العمل على البطاله تقلل الفاعل اضيف الى
كل ده طبعا
حريات على مستوى الاجتماع وعلى المستوى
السياسي لانه علمانيه بدو ليبراليه يبقى
نموذج يبدا نجاح هذا المثلث في محاصره
الافكار وصعبه مش بس انهم بيواجهوا والدول
بدعمه ترفع شعار الاسلام هو الحل ولد يشعر
اكثر جاذبيه لكثير واسهل في الترويج من
الشعار العلمانيه والحل ولكن في خلق ظروف
اقتصاديه وسياسيه تسمح بنجاح نموذج اللي
بيرو اليه وكمان علشان تشجع ملايين ملايين
من الشباب اللي هو كمان في مكه فيه شباب
او كوادر المتطرفه لكن في الملايين من
الشباب اتمنى ان يعيش حياه معتدله ويعيش
حياه زى اللى يشوفها في المجتمعات الغربيه
الممكن لا يحسن زي ما اقول لحضراتكم لما
توفر فرص النجاح اللي هي مرتبطه بنجاح
التنميه والحريات العامه والخاصه اشكركم
والى لقاء اخر ان شاء الله
[موسيقى]